très aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra et
aussi longtemps que cela sera nécessaire
ça ne veut pas dire intégrer
immédiatement l'Ukraine Jean-Louis
broland ah non ce sont deux choses
différentes il y a d'abord le LED que
nous apportons à l'Ukraine pour qu'elle
recouvre sa souveraineté sur le
territoire qui lui est
internationalement reconnu ça c'est une
chose et d'autre part parce qu'elle l'a
demandé sa volonté répondre à sa volonté
d'intégration qui est un processus qui
est sur un autre rythme qui a mobilise
d'autres logiques et qui doit
effectivement être pris en compte parce
qu'on voit bien que ce combat que mène
l'Ukraine c'est un combat qui engage en
profondeur les valeurs de toute l'Europe
donc il y a là quelque chose qui est
devenu beaucoup plus pressant beaucoup
plus urgent mais la réalisation prendra
du temps et et surtout il ne faut pas il
ne faut pas s'en inquiéter il faut pas
s'en inquiéter il faut il faut marcher
vers l'intégration
maintenant en faisant ce qui est
nécessaire pour que cette intégration
soit réussie c'est une affaire à long
terme voilà c'est une affaire à à long
terme nous allons revenir sur les
conditions qui sont toujours posées
lorsqu'un pays veut adhérer à l'Union
européenne mais l'Ukraine fait le forcer
là Jean-Luc là non je crois pas
elle ne peut adhérer qu'à partir du
moment où la situation est militaire
internationale et rétablie elle est
simplement c'est la distinction entre la
candidature et l'adhésion est très
pertinente on l'a admis comme candidate
ça veut dire qu'elle est éligible
qu'elle fait partie de la famille ce qui
ne veut pas dire que elle puisse être
devenir membre immédiatement mais
j'insiste sur un point
les Français sont toujours été vis-à-vis
de tous les élargissements réticents
dans un premier temps il y a un réflexe
pavlovia en France qui est de dire on
est bien entre nous si l'Europe se
limitait à la France à l'Allemagne et au
Benelux et ce serait on serait parfait
on a été contre l'Espagne on a été
contre le roi le Royaume-Uni on a été
contre l'Europe de l'Est et puis après
aussi fait mais là donc le le il faut
pas c'est un point de départ si vous
voulez le les 52 48 et je trouve qu'il
est intéressant de voir car c'est assez
nouveau que sur ce plan-là nous sommes
comme vous l'avez dit nous sommes
synchrone avec l'opinion allemande ça
c'est une c'est une nouveauté c'est une
nouveauté on est toujours on traîne
beaucoup
Jean-Louis oui il y a des prières
réticents les Pays-Bas pour des raisons
financières la France et l'Allemagne
aussi non mais il y a des pays prudents
qui sont attachés au bon fonctionnement
de l'Union européenne telle qu'elle
s'est construit depuis le 9 mai 1950
sous la houlade de Jean Monnet etc sont
évidemment très soucieux que cette
élargissement ne se traduise pas par une
dilution et là l'exemple de la Pologne
et de la Hongrie s'inquiète parce que
nous avons beaucoup d'admiration pour
les Polonais mais on voit bien que ils
ont insidieusement et même
officiellement remise en cause une
partie du pacte qu'il ait notamment la
fameuse suprématie du droit supériorité
du droit communautaire qui est inhérent
un bon fonctionnement de l'Union
européenne donc ce que nous ce que nous
ce qui était essentiel ce qui était
essentiel pour que l'Ukraine réussisse
son son intégration c'est pas qu'elles
deviennent riches on a on a on est
capable d'accueillir des pays qui ne
sont pas riches c'est d'une part
qu'elles prennent de très sérieusement
ce qui est dans le programme desinski
contre la corruption notamment la
modification de de la clé de voûte du
système judiciaire qui est actuellement
beaucoup trop beaucoup trop lié à un
ancien régime oligarchique ça c'est
c'est absolument fondamental tant que
vraiment le toit la toilette n'aura pas
été faite sur en grande largeur et puis
et deuxièmement qu'on se met d'accord
qu'on accepte car c'est une des
conditions qui a été posée il y a déjà
40 années le critères de Copenhague
consommait d'accord pour que l'Union
européenne soit elle-même capable
d'accueillir vous ne pouvez pas
fonctionner à l'unanimité si vous faites
vous faites venir un tas de gens qui
sont pas toujours d'accord à ce
moment-là les nouveaux venus vous
paralysent c'est ce que c'est de faire
Orban a bien des égards dis NON je
m'oppose non seulement je veux pas pour
moi mais je vous empêche de les autres
et ça on ne le veut pas donc il y a il y
a tout un travail qui a posé d'ailleurs
le chancelier le chancelier allemand
dans son discours à Prague et qui
correspond à ce que pense Emmanuel
Macron il y a un travail de de
d'approfondissement institutionnel qui
est la clé de l'élargissement bien nous
vivons cette histoire en ce moment
européenne doit-elle intégrer l'Ukraine
le plus rapidement possible on a vu les
difficultés alors regardons Jean-Louis
Bour change l'Union l'Ukraine a beaucoup
d'efforts à faire avant d'entrer dans
l'Union européenne réforme structurelle
on parlait de corruption meilleure
démocratie parlementaire il faut des
élections libres il faut je ne sais pas
moi
il faut des médias parfaitement
indépendants il y a beaucoup de
conditions avant une adhésion c'est le
programme de même quand on Moldavie
c'est le programme de la présidente de
Moldavie ce sont des gens qui sont
justement c'est pour ça qu'il y a une
dynamique ce sont des gens qui sont
porteurs au sein d'un pays qui n'est pas
habitué à cette liberté que vous écrivez
qui n'est pas habitué au pluralisme qui
n'est pas habitué là ce sont des gens
qui sont au pouvoir et qui sont porteurs
de tout ça et c'est pour ça qu'il y a
une énorme dynamique oui il y a une
énorme dynamique vous avez raison mais
on a un peu tendance par l'agresseur est
russe personne ne remet ça en doute mais
on a un peu tendance à prendre à un peu
en France et pas et ailleurs en Europe
peut-être à fermer les yeux sur la
réalité crânienne je veux dire par là de
justice qui n'est peut-être pas encore
tout à fait indépendante et des médias
qui ne sont pas très indépendants non
plus c'est ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure l'Ukraine n'a pas du tout HP ça
aurait eu démocratique simplement ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'elle l'a
déclenché on va dire à Maïda enfin avant
mais en tout cas à Madame est-ce que
c'est justement là-dessus qu'elle s'est
accrochée avec la Russie ce que n'a pas
accepté la Russie c'est que le destin de
l'Ukraine puisse ressembler à celui
d'une démocratie européenne alors que ce
que voudrait Poutine c'est qu'elle
ressemble au destin de la Biélorussie et
et c'est là c'est là où il y a vraiment
deux camps il y a le camp de la
démocratie et nous sommes nous sommes
dans la même dynamique alors ensuite
vous posez le problème du rythme le plus
tôt possible on verra mais ce qui ce qui
était essentiel c'est de marcher dans la
même direction et effectivement il ne
faut pas faire là vous avez tout à fait
raison une adhésion au rabais en
sacrifiant des enjeux font la mentaux en
termes de lutte contre la corruption en
termes de liberté en termes
d'acceptation des règles du jeu européen
au nom de la guerre en quelque sorte au
nom du sang je dirais au nom du sang je
pose la question parce que c'est une
question que beaucoup se posent est-ce
que non du sang on doit faciliter
l'adhésion de l'Union européenne au nom
du au nom du son on doit au nom du sang
comme pour reprendre votre expression on
doit défendre aider l'Ukraine à se
libérer oui c'est une guerre on dit
Ukraine veut la PS qu'on veut la
victoire l'Ukraine veut la libération au
sens où nous entendions ce mot en 1945
la libération l'Ukraine est là on doit
payer pour ça on doit donner des armes
on doit
organiser des sanctions et elles ne sont
parfois elles sont parfois coûteuses on
doit faire des efforts importants
constants durable et c'est ça ensuite
l'adhésion c'est autre chose c'est la
mais il faut bien voir aussi une chose
c'est que l'Ukraine en adhérent à
l'Union européenne
va donner une dimension géopolitique
nouvelle au projet européen le projet
européen c'était un projet d'échange de
progrès économiques de modernisation de
coopération mais la politique c'est
autre chose la politique c'est aussi la
confrontation la défense des valeurs
l'exigence de réciprocité par rapport à
des partenaires qui nous veulent du mal
et toutes ces valeurs là elles sont
contenues dans la Résistance ukrainienne
donc je crois qu'il y a un
enrichissement du projet européen par
l'Ukraine qui est possible alors il y a
une question qui fâche après en
attendant Jean-Philippe Dubrulle et donc
avec nous et veut aussi apporter sa
pierre à notre discussion
on parle de l'adhésion mais encore
faut-il pour qu'elle se fasse que les
hostilités cessent on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure et pour revenir pour que les
hostilités cessent ou pas je vois pas
comment on pourrait organiser
une adhésion
on a fait ça avec Chypre on a fait
rentrer
on a vu qu'on a vraiment eu de très peu
n'importe quoi
c'est pour ça qu'il faut aider aussi ben
parce que aider l'Ukraine à récupérer sa
soif c'est faciliter l'adhésion voilà je
ne vois pas comment on peut on peut
raisonnablement avec les les
informations dont on dispose prévoir une
donnée une date précise pour la la fin
des hostilités en réalité pour qu'il y
ait pour qu'il y ait un accord pour
qu'il y ait un accord il faut bon c'est
clair vous ne pouvez pas sur une
situation équilibrée comme elle est
militairement actuellement vous ne
pouvez pas trouver des interlocuteurs
l'Ukraine ne peut pas dire vous avez
raison est-ce qu'aujourd'hui compte tenu
de la situation militaire équilibrée sur
le terrain est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il est
possible d'ouvrir des négociations si je
dis non vous êtes d'accord avec moi ou
pas non moi je dis je dis effectivement
que c'est impossible quel serait les
termes est-ce que vous croyez imaginons
qu'en 1915 on guère avec l'Allemagne on
dit bah écoutez on va ouvrir les trucs
l'Allemagne occupe la Picardie le
Nord-Pas-de-Calais etc on va vous
laisser ça on va garder le reste de la
France c'est évidemment inacceptable
équivalent pour Zelinski il peut pas
accepter qu'une partie de son territoire
il a été envahi il y a l'objet d'une
agression et à l'inverse à l'inverse
vous n'imaginez pas que Poutine puisse
dire bah voilà il y a eu 200000 morts
j'ai fait tout ça une opération
militaire spéciale on arrête on rentre
tous chez nous donc l'évolution elle ne
peut elle ne peut venir que de deux
choses soit et là nous l'avons un
déséquilibre militaire soit un
changement de pouvoir en Russie ça
personne n'y contre rien etc je suis
bien incapable de dire si c'est possible
ou pas personne sinon le rapport de
force et le rapport de force il peut
évoluer dans les deux sens soit les
Ukrainiens peuvent être avec un effort
considérable des Russes peuvent être
battus et obligés d'accepter des
conditions ép c'est ce qui nous est
arrivé en 1871 face au pression on a
accès on a perdu l'Alsace-Lorraine parce
qu'on avait perdu la guerre bien sûr
l'inverse une une victoire de libération
de l'Ukraine qui libère les territoires
et à ce moment-là
Poutine qui dit oui bah ça on est obligé
donc il y aura forcément de ce point de
vue là non pas une victoire totale il y
aura discussion quand il y aura le
rapport de force que nous devons
continuer à aider l'Ukraine est-ce que
l'Ukraine dans l'Union européenne serait
un cheval de Troie américain en Europe
qui veut répondre moi je veux bien je
crois non écoutez je crois que la
solidarité entre l'Ukraine et les
États-Unis et les États-Unis est
évidentes la solidarité des États-Unis
avec l'ensemble de l'Union européenne
est évidente ce que nous avons vu à
travers cette querelle
le maintien le rétablissement de ce lien
transatlantique fondamental qui a
d'ailleurs accompagné d'un bout à
l'autre depuis 50 la création de l'Union
européenne nous avons bien vu que la
profondeur stratégique de la défense
européenne c'était l'Atlantique alors
effectivement ce que dit ce que dit la
France elle le dit depuis longtemps elle
l'a dit avec de Gaulle elle le dit
aujourd'hui avec Emmanuel Macron ce que
dit la France et qu'on ne peut pas se
satisfaire de cette situation parce
qu'on ne sait pas ce que demain les
États-Unis feront et effectivement quand
on voit par exemple ce café Trump fait
Trump n'est pas n'est pas mort
politiquement c'est parce qu'il va
devenir mais il est pas mort
politiquement il y avait une il y avait
la crainte d'une
d'un abandon de leur Trump était
quelqu'un qui considérait que son
adversaire c'était l'Allemagne
c'est la compétiteur économique etc donc
ce que nous disons nous Français c'est
que il faut renforcer le pôle européen
de sécurité mais nous rencontrons et
même même les Polonais même les Baltes
qui sont extrêmement pro-américains ils
étaient très conscients il y a un an et
demi avant cette affaire ukrainienne que
les États-Unis dérivaient vers autre
chose s'occuper des Chinois risquez leur
demander de s'entendre